if you live in la you know this is kind
of a big deal here los angeles ban on
plastic straws went into effect last
week that's a big thing here apparently
the new law is being very strictly
enforced no plastic straws that's the
rule and this law is leading to
situations like this take a look
don't
oh it's move
this has been a public service
announcement reminding you when doing
cocaine please don't use a plastic straw
why not snort it off a house key instead
or roll up a 100 bill like they do in
the movies
the edge of a long hunting knife would
work too
you could grow one fingernail really
long
or you could ask an assistant to blow
the cocaine directly into your butthole
just like i heard rockstars in the 1970s
used to do oh well
different times i guess
different times
real good times